pl tutti ragazzi benvenuti che sono
video sono fa dj chi non si sa lo sa
perché non è che si può fare sempre è
prevista domenica quindi no non per
stadi cacciabili fare pd smuove il culo
solo infilo stanotte da tutti ragazzi e
benvenute che sono video sono fa vj egli
sia uno snap mills perché va bene che
siamo su happy with cazzo da quando ho
iniziato sto gioco se questa roba
sei un film diceva da quando iniziato
sto gioco non è mai successo nella mia
vita di non riuscire a fare un
impossible e non sarà questa la prossima
volta usa il preservativo fa meno male
fatemi capire staccati touch e
bellissimo fammi capire un uomo cos'hai
nel cervello
ho tirato una testata non questo voglio
rivedere cioè ho tirato un attestato a
lampione cioè ma spiegatemi il senso ce
la farò prima o poi non è così difficile
sì esatto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
coi gomiti e vabbè come fa a caso ho
vinto qualche bella sirena che sei steve
white folle thing questo a questo questo
sono già un fenomeno quindi sì perché
c'è il padre di uk che si sta suicidando
questo voglio vedere dove andare a
prenderlo tipo al volo come cosa faccia
prenderlo non ce la faccio
bello beh sono fenomeno sti giochi
all'inizio ora impossibile si ok
bene bene va bene così basta non ne
voglio più sapere se ho provato a
prenderlo ci ho messo tutta la mia buona
volontà grop swing facciamo questo che è
meglio non seriamente il senso è dalla
parte sbagliatissima ok ci arrivò a una
mira incredibile è difficile fare sti
livelli ma quando no [ __ ] ciao fatta
spingi spingi million parco perfetto
basta non ne voglio più vedere di rock
swing per tutta la mia vita pubblica in
taggia in do ben noti in posti volo
capito tutto starò a devo saltarlo cos'è
successo perché assieme partito ok già
fatta no vinco io vinco io beh qualche
stronzo rai perfetto per questa volta
vinco io per fatti non ci sono arrivato
merda è una roba allucinata e così ma
non ci credo non è possibile finirlo gen
devi essere superman per arrivare a caso
bene mezz'ora ci ho messo per farlo no
che luogo flight devo volare colpo steve
fammi vedere che se qualcosa perché se
non c'è croci cos'è quella roba lì
wolverine è proprio uguale a polveri
sono diventato un unicorno un unicorno
sexy per porta e la spada che ciò è
infilata nel pube ragazzi lui è messo
peggio una cosa orribile ragazzi niente
sono morto basta mi sono rotto i
[ __ ]
e stato a quel traguardo pure grazie di
avermi preso per il culo che state
facendo e cos'è kamasutra lega parkour
fail cos'è sta o mio dio
cos'è sta roba sei un fenomeno fattelo
dire calma amico 26 spaventato successo
amico mio
devi capire che non puoi a buttarti
sulle bozze buttato sulle botte in
deficiente ma fa da solo a caso qui sia
minchia
salve ragazzi io devo capire a cosa
cazzo appena giocato legame lo sapete
dire io non ho capito niente ischemiche
siepi le boxini mancarci sisti livelli
con l'ansia proprio nell'anima mi
mancavano miglia che mira quasi schede
ho vinto un genio ma spesso troppo forse
diventato un fenomeno è ormai non ha più
segreti questo gioco per me inutile
imporsi voice to fini cioè la madonna
no non ce la faccio capaci capaccio ce
la faccio ce la posso fare ma per non sa
quante volta scritti in posti che
secondo te è impossibile perchè non
l'hai non è mica scritto tante volte i
ratei fai vedere che la nutella non la
stai mangiando da un casini te si no
cosa si
ansa
l'ho fatta sono le soddisfazioni della
vita ragazza ma è nel countdown
ma john maynard keynes dons one le leggi
big bounce libertà a tutti amiamo lato e
vabbè minchia che è rovesciata
vabbè basta che questa è la scena più
epica di happy with della storia non so
neanche come ho fatto io ho fatto ho
vinto ma non sono morto tutti i cani
mitica ricami tutti che chi juric e poi
trova hard facciamo questo che mi piace
vai così uim 4 palle molto felici perché
si può fare intendere questa cosa no no
no sì sì perfetto grandi passiamo al
prossimo anno
bring me nun then there will espace
perfetto ragazzi fatemi andare dove
stanno cavo che cos'è ho superato uno
star non avevo neanche visto ma iniziare
ma sono fenomeno al nord da oggi
smistando da 10 penso io da solo sei
licenziato ha davvero bene in faccia
adesso arriva il colpo di grazia sia
preparati soca una donna che botta
mi chiamo massacrato
quando c'è quando si trova bravo sono
troppo bravo che è partito york ho vinto
e grazie volevo dirvi ragazzi che
ultimamente record come cazzo faccio che
sono sul come faccio che sono in bici ma
deve vincere io credo dice io do vincere
io faccio bombe non ci posso mai
arrivati se invece si le braccia verso
le braccia ma che sica di merda
va bene non so dove sono finito ma va
bene
you can not due è stato abbastanza
semplice no vabbè non puoi fare una cosa
del genere invece ho vinto a caso
ragazzi io non so cosa mi sta mi stia
prendendo in questo episodio di è primis
ma riesce a vincere tutto non si sa
perché rock swing caribbean cos'è sta
roba è una roba che è figo ma che figata
su nola bene queste da vinto tutto però
sono morto no vabbè mica con con lo
stato un affacciata sulla spiaggia
incredibile no vabbè ragazzi ma è un
genio che ha fatto sta cosa
guardalo madonna un fenomeno che come io
non ci ho pensato prima neanch'io fare
una cosa la barca sulla bara o mio dio
cosa sono quelli no dai ha vinto tutto
posso andare avanti grazie prima io
gamba prima io e stronzi di merda fa di
questa pratica fermi un attimo ma è
impossibile se no no no no sì
madonna si dica non ce ne sono più ti
prego e quanti cazzo sono basta non ci
sono troppi sarei tutta la vita dunque
ragazzi per fare un paio di livelli su
di me perché ecco perché pof vj e il
rapimento ciafani jj sono un tuo fan
mandami l'amicizia su playstation 3
no no alla playstation 3 ok gli occhi ha
rapito la nota afferma l'ho capito ma
come fa un bambino birra perché pensa la
via non puoi scalarlo ti conviene morire
guarda ti potrei uccidere nella vita
reale ascoltami zio fammi capire un
attimo senso di questa cosa invece lo
schivato [ __ ] non so come sia possibile
che non lo si è ribellato lui tenta di
suicidarsi vai con lui per la vittoria
dove devo andare andati sotto
veramente che problemi hai avuto prima
di fare questo livello amico miapa vj e
la vendetta di bob bob much of a man o
bob che non ha le braccia ma perché
vorrei sapere cosa hai contro contro di
me non ho niente bob non è colpa mia se
tu non è le braccia per colpa tua non
sono felice mela me la pagherai devo
dare una mela va p ma nava mattino
qualche punto in più che io ti osservo
mio dio cercare cosa che grazie io non
dormino più nella mia vita non ci credo
mancato il traguardo
ragazzi stato non voglio neanche dopo il
finale tragico così non voglio più
vedere niente nella mia vita
dietro tutti ragazzi conclude episodio
spero che video vi sia piaciuto anche
bob non mi piace sono delle braccia per
bob sei video è piaciuto a cose
calciatore che mi piace anche a faccia
di facebook e condivido stata una
descrizione teorici di sky tree ci
vediamo al prossimo bella ragazzi